Voici ma minute de gloire,
mon discours d'acceptation,
et voici le canard.
C'est sa première fois sur la côte ouest américaine.
Je vais le faire passer
(Rires)
Oui ?
Vous pouvez le faire passer.
Veuillez noter qu'il s'agit d'un spécimen de musée,
mais aucun risque d'attraper la grippe aviaire.
Après avoir remporté ce prix, ma vie a changé.
D'abord les gens ont commencé à m'envoyer
toutes sortes de choses liées aux canards,
et j'ai une très belle collection.
(Rires)
Surtout,
les gens ont commencé à me faire parvenir leurs observations
de comportements remarquables des animaux,
et croyez-moi, s'il y a un animal qui se comporte de manière bizarre sur cette planète,
je suis au courant.
(Rires)
Voici un élan.
C'est un élan qui essaye de s’accoupler
avec une statue en bronze d'un bison.
Ici c'est dans le Montana en 2008.
Il s'agit d'une grenouille qui essaie de s'accoupler avec un poisson rouge.
Ici c'est aux Pays-Bas en 2011.
Voici des crapauds en Australie.
Voici un accident de la route.
Veuillez noter que c'est de la nécrophilie.
C'est remarquable : la position.
La position du missionnaire est très rare dans le règne animal.
Voici des pigeons à Rotterdam.
Des hirondelles à Hong Kong, 2004.
Voici une dinde dans le Wisconsin
dans les locaux de l'Ethan Allen, un établissement pénitentiaire pour mineurs.
Il nous a fallu toute une journée,
et les prisonniers se sont bien amusés.
Qu'est-ce que cela signifie ?
La question que je me pose,
pourquoi cela se produit-il dans la nature ?
Eh bien, ce que j'ai conclu
en analysant tous ces cas,
c'est que c'est important que ça se passe
uniquement lorsque la mort est instantanée
et d'une manière dramatique
et dans la bonne position pour l'accouplement.
Du moins, c'est ce que je pensais jusqu'à ce que je ne voie ces diapositives.
Là, vous voyez un canard mort.
Il est là depuis trois jours,
et il est couché sur le dos.
Donc, voilà ma théorie sur la nécrophilie.
Un autre exemple de l'impact
des bâtiments en verre sur la vie des oiseaux.
Voici Mad Max, un merle qui vit à Rotterdam.
La seule chose que cet oiseau a fait c'est de voler contre cette fenêtre
de 2004 à 2008, jour après jour.
Le voilà, et voici une courte vidéo.
(Musique) (Bruit sourd)
(Bruit sourd)
Alors, ce que fait cet oiseau
c'est lutter contre sa propre image.
Il voit un intrus dans son territoire,
il arrive tout le temps et il est toujours là,
il n'y a donc pas de fin.
Et j'ai pensé au début -- j'ai étudié cet oiseau pendant deux ou trois ans --
le cerveau de cet oiseau ne devrait-il pas être endommagé ?
Il ne l'est pas. Je vous montre quelques diapositives,
certaines images de la vidéo,
et au dernier moment avant de heurter la vitre,
il met les pattes en avant,
ensuite il se cogne contre la vitre.
Je vais terminer en vous invitant à la Journée du Canard Mort.
C'est le 5 Juin de chaque année.
L'après-midi à six heures moins cinq
nous nous réunissons au Musée d'Histoire Naturelle de Rotterdam,
le canard sort du musée,
et nous essayons de discuter de nouvelles façons
d'empêcher les oiseaux de s'écraser contre les fenêtres.
Et comme vous le savez peut-être,
c'est l'une des principales causes de décès
des oiseaux dans le monde.
Aux Etats-Unis uniquement, un milliard d'oiseaux meurent
écrasés contre des bâtiments en verre.
Et quand c'est fini, nous allons au restaurant chinois
et nous avalons six plats de canard.
J'espère donc vous voir
l'an prochain à Rotterdam, aux Pays-Bas,
pour la Journée du Canard Mort.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)
Oh, excusez-moi.
Puis-je avoir mon canard, s'il vous plaît?
(Rires) (Applaudissements)
Merci.